وفي المقابل التامه وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
برو واشنطن وحلفائها باتباع نهج لعسكره
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ واكد لظروف عدم
اصدار بيان مشترك عن قمه اسيان بسبب موقف
امريكا وشركائها بشان اوكرانيا واعتبر ان
واشنطن نجحت في زرع الشك في رابطه اسيا
لم تتخذ اي قرارات جماعيه اليوم عقب اسرار
الولايات المتحده وشركائها الغربيين على
لهجه غير مقبوله على الاطلاق فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في اوكرانيا وهذا ما تسبب في عدم
اصدار بيان مشترك بشان اجتماعات القمه لو
كان الهدف زرع الشك في رابطه اسيا وتقويض
التجانسها بشكل عام ناجح الامريكيون في
تحقيق اهدافهم
وتم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه واشنطن
وحلفاءها بمحاولات السيطره عسكريه على
اسيا والمحيط الهادي
لتقويض واحتواء المصالح الروسيه والصينيه
في المنطقه وقال لو ظروف في ختام قمه
قياسيين ان واشنطن تسعى لتوسيع تحالف
اوكرانيا من خلال اغراء اليابان وكندا
ونيوزيلندا بلنضمام اليه
وديه
ومنذ وقت ليس ببعيد طرح مفهوم استراتيجيه
المحيطين الهندي
مع الهياكل الشامله التي تم انشائها حول
اسيا وتنتوي على عسكرت هذه المنطقه مع
التركيز الواضحه على احتواء الصين
والمصالح الروسيه فيها احد المظاهر
الملموسه لمثل هذا المسار انشاء تحالفوس
العسكريه الذي يحاول الان بنشاط تم
يزيلندا وكندا واليابان